[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous mercredi 28 février
bienvenue dans le statut de journal sur
tv 78 tour d'horizon de l'actualité
locale et régionale
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition faire progresser la recherche
sur les nanotechnologies objectifs du
nouvel institut l est ne nanotech
installé au sein du laboratoire national
de métrologie et d'essais de trappes
il a été inauguré hier mardi c'était en
présence de la secrétaire d'état delfina
génie stefan reportage à suivre notre
dossier de la semaine est consacrée à
l'agriculture alors que se tient en ce
moment le salon e du secteur à paris
dans les yvelines
les exploitants utilisent de plus en
plus les nouvelles technologies drones
et gps et robots aidé les agriculteurs
au quotidien elle nous avons suivi l'un
d'entre eux à saint martin de brett en
cours et puis elle a été confirmée pour
cinq ans la direction du théâtre
montansier de versailles est reconduite
jusqu'en 2023 geneviève dichamp et
frédéric franck reste à la tête et de la
scène qui vient de fêter ses deux cent
quarante ans pour en parler justement
geneviève dichamp est notre invité et
puis autre invité de ce journal
joséphine coleman ce berger maire de
plaisir qui viendra nous parler de sa
ville qui est actuellement en mutation
plus personne dehors le message est
clair l'action elle ce soir mercredi une
cinquantaine d'élus franciliens dont des
yvelinois vont passer la nuit dehors à
paris ils sont de tous bords politiques
confondus et mène cette opération en
soutien aux personnes qui vivent dans la
rue c'est sans abri sont
particulièrement exposés et menacé face
aux températures négatives du moment à
-2° encore attendus pour cette nuit de
mercredi à jeudi
l initiative a été lancée par massy
maire adjointe de la vie la détente en
essonne je vous propose de l'écouter
parce qu'on veut c'est vraiment alerter
nos pairs sur cette situation qui n'est
plus acceptable et donc du coup on va on
va formuler des doléances ce soir je
suis militante associative éducatrice
mais c'est qu'à un moment donné on se
rend bien compte que le citoyen une
limité dans ses actions on peut
distribuer des soutes du café on peut
donner des vêtements mais en réalité ça
ne change rien à la situation de la
personne
le lendemain c'est pareil donc la lande
et dernière maraude les
960 pas gêné de me le rappeler et ils
ont eu raison
et du coup je me suis dit bon on a tout
essayé
essayons maintenant la dernière haïti ça
va être la carte politique
côté météo la neige devrait faire son
retour cette nuit dont les yvelines le
département est placé en vigilance
orange par météo france
un à trois centimètres de neige est
attendue poids lourds et bus sont d'ores
et déjà interdits à la circulation sur
la nationale 118 et ce à partir de 22
heures la préfecture des yvelines
appelle d'ailleurs demain elle les
automobilistes à utiliser de préférence
les transports en commun le plan grand
froid reste lui actif dans les yvelines
il a permis à depuis son déclenchement
d'ouvrir 3102 places supplémentaires
d'hébergement en ile de france indique
la préfecture de région à mesure et
l'infiniment petit une activité
désormais impossible à trappes avec le
nouvel institut ellen nanotech il a été
inauguré hier mardi en présence de la
secrétaire d'état auprès auprès du
auprès du ministre de l'économie et
delphine est génie et stefan installé
dans les locaux du laboratoire national
d'essais et de métrologie cet outil va
permettre de faire progresser nos
connaissances sur les nanotechnologies
et les précisions avec ce sujet
d'aurélie rond et nicolas kirillovitch
voici un microscope à force atomique
métrologique cet outil de pointe unique
en france fait partie des équipements du
nouvel institut ellen nanotech
intégré au sein du laboratoire national
d'essai et de métrologie
l'institut est en charge de la
réalisation des références à l'échelle
du nanomètre
il a notamment comme objectif de
développer les nanotechnologies vous
avez des applications par exemple sur
les d'écart autonettoyante n'ai plus
besoin de nettoyer vos carreaux vous
avez des textiles qui ne sentent pas
mauvais parce qu'ils sont anti bactérien
vous avez des applications dans la santé
extrêmement importante
par exemple dans le traitement de
certains cancers
depuis plus de dix ans où elle est née
cette équipe de recherche travaillent
sur les nanomatériaux et les nano
dispositif une activité en plein essor
appelé à jouer un rôle important dans le
monde de demain
c'est absolument clé pour l'industrie et
en particulier toute une série
d'industries innovantes dans le domaine
du semiconducteur dans le monde aussi
dans le domaine alimentaire
pharmaceutique puisque les nanomatériaux
sont de plus en plus utilisés dans
l'industrie pour leurs propriétés
particulières une nouvelle technologie
source d'inquiétude d'où l'utilité de ce
nouvel institut sont des particules tout
petit qui peuvent franchir les barrières
biologiques de façon avec des propriétés
tout à fait incroyable et donc il faut
mieux les connaître mieux les
caractérise et c'est ce qu'on va faire
ici objectif pour l'institut ellen
nanotech devenir un opérateur de
référence au niveau national mais aussi
international
une ville en évolution plaisir à lens
hénin grandes phases de travaux de
requalification de la place de l'église
saint-pierre cinq mois de chantier pour
réhabiliter le mur séparant la place du
parc du château de plaisir bonsoir
joséphine coleman berger dans sa lettre
la mer les républicains de plaisir ces
travaux vont être complétés d'un
réaménagement
usagers du parc du château de plaisir on
ajoute à cela l'on passé vous avez mené
une concertation au public dans la ville
pour imaginer l'évolution du
centre-bourg dire ce que le centre bourg
à quoi il va leur ressembler à quoi il
va ressembler dans les prochaines années
c'est important d'être sans cesse en
mutation en mutation je sais pas si
c'est le bon approprié je dirais plutôt
en prospective par rapport à ce qu'on
imagine
parce que c'est c'est fondamental je
dirais de travailler pour demain et pour
après demain le quotidien c'est quelque
chose de fondamental certes mais
envisager comment l'évolution doit se
faire sur une collectivité c'est
fondamental et le sujet dont vous me
parlez effectivement fait partie aussi
d'une première étape parce qu'il y en
aura bien d'autres
on aura bien d'autres on va peut-être
rien dans cet entretien alors si on
présente cette place de l'église saint
pierre elle est délimitée d'un côté par
l'église de l'autre par ce mur du parc
du château c'est une place qui s'est
agrandie dans le temps puisque elle a
finalement aux piles étaient un petit
peu sur le parc du château de plaisir
c'est une place qui a beaucoup bougé à
travers les siècles puisqu'on a retrouvé
des documents qui nous ont permis de
voir que le mur du château s'est déplacé
au coeur au cours du temps mais
aujourd'hui c'est une continuité par
rapport aux travaux que nous avons fait
sur l'église
il ya quelques années ou 7 millions
d'euros étaient investis dans cette
église qui a été refaite complètement
parce que c'était une église qui allait
s'effondrer et donc suite à ça il était
question de refaire la place de l'église
pas tellement pour l'agrandir mais
surtout pour lui redonner je dirais une
logique de visibilité par rapport au
parc du château et surtout le château du
xviiie qui n'étaient pas visibles parce
que le mur était quelque chose qui était
un rempart physalies du parc donc
aujourd'hui on va leur faire justement
cette place est devenue un parc de
stationnement dans les années 1960
pourquoi le lard qualifié cette place
finalement vous en avez dit deux mots
mais pourquoi c'était primordial pour la
ville et c'était primordial déjà parce
que vous savez que rhdp is âgées c'est
important on était dans du minéral
aujourd'hui on souhaite mettre beaucoup
plus de végétalisation et puis aussi
parce que le mur était un petit peu en
diagonale on voulait le redresser ça a
été effectivement un chantier difficile
aussi avec les bâtiments de france et
avec la drieu qui nous qui nous
demandaient bien sûr pourquoi nous
voulions faire cela et c'est pour ça et
vous l'avez évoqué vous même qu'on
contrepartie nous allons refaire le parc
à l'intérieur au niveau des armées au
niveau 2 il ya eu pas mal je dirais de
changements ces derniers jours en tout
cas sa part qu'il ya une première
tranche de travaux qui est prévu donc ça
c'est pour le mur qui sépare la la place
du parc du château
cinq mois et demi de travaux deuxième
tranche vous en avez dit deux mots ça va
durer cinq mois
et là c'est la requalification paysagère
de ce parc du château de plaisir
plantation d'arbres et d'arbustes
création des reprises d'aller pause et
déplacements de bon on peut aussi parler
du curage du bassin et aussi des du
bassin du canal et aussi des fossés et
ses travaux c'était on va dire dans le
deal il fallait il fallait se refaire
surface
et oui mais en même temps ça nous
arrange bien parce que refaire le
château sert faire qu'on va faire le
château d'ailleurs on va refaire aussi
château avec les fenêtres on a une
centaine de fenêtres à refaire
intégralement d'accord donc ça fait
partie aussi du projet mais pour
reparler de la végétalisation oui on a
dû couper des arbres ça a été vraiment
un arrache coeur de notre part parce
qu'on avait une futaie à l'entrée et il
était nécessaire d'après les bâtiments
de france il à drieu de remettre dans le
concept du xviiie siècle le fond du parc
puisque ce canal et le fond du parquet
pour la visibilité il était important de
refaire des arbustes
on va en replanter quatre fois plus
important on va faire aussi un verger et
maintenant avec ce mur qui va être
entrecoupée de cris on aura une
visibilité totale sur le parc sur le
château et sur cette refonte complète du
parc du château avec bien sûr les armes
dont je vous parlais mais aussi de canal
qui est un canal important et qui va
être remis en état il ya des poissons
d'accord et les pêcheurs et c'est
important bien sûr que tout ça reprenne
un petit peu le style qu'il avait au
xviiie siècle et toujours des
difficultés à faire ce genre travaux ou
disais tout à l'heure être en accord
avec le respect bien sûr des monuments
historiques d
lieu historique c'est toujours difficile
de lancer ce genre travaux c'est
compliqué parce que nous les élus bien
on a des volontés on a des désirs et
malgré tout et bien il faut appliquer ce
que nous demandent les bâtiments de
france dans le respect bien sûr du
patrimoine je suis très respectueux de
la loi
donc c'était assez compliqué d'accepter
certaines choses comme la coupe de césar
mayoro fall a beaucoup reproché mais
comme je sais qu'on va replanter d'une
autre façon et beaucoup plus que ce
qu'il n'y avait on peut être que
satisfait de tout cela donc ça rentre
vraiment dans une réflexion totale du
parc de la place du mur et du château
dans un deuxième temps puisqu'on a un
très gros projet au niveau du château et
des comme un autre sujet et qui témoigne
de cette évolution a plaisir à quoi
ressemblera la ville de plaisir dans dix
vingt ou trente ans c'est la question
que vous avez posé l'an passé vous aviez
lancé une concertation publique sur
l'évolution du centre bourg trois
secteurs sont concernés on va peut-être
les voir à l'image le centre historique
l'hôpital et les jardins familiaux un
cycle le valley bout cette concertation
a été fructueuse menée auprès des
habitants
elle a été fructueuse et surtout est ça
m'a permis de remettre en explications
qu'est ce que c'est que d'abord un
diagnostic
nous avons présenté le diagnostic de ces
trois secteurs et un diagnostic ça veut
bien dire que rien n'est décidé
aujourd'hui nous rentrons dans la phase
d'étude de faisabilité et c'est ce qui
est en train de se faire aujourd'hui sur
le vélib ou puisque c'est le premier
quartier que nous sommes en train de
remettre en place puisque comme vous le
savez il ya une réhabilitation complète
qui se fait la démolition du silo qui
est en cours d'ailleurs et qui va ouvrir
ce quartier complètement à la ville et
au centre ville puisque le quartier et
placée en centre ville et si nous avons
fait cette étude
et bien c'est bien sûr pour réfléchir à
plaisir dans 20 ans mais c'est aussi
parce que nous avions 20 hectares en
centre ville qui comme qui se libéraient
parce que nous avons une fusion des deux
hôpitaux et il fallait véritablement que
nous ayons de réflexion pour ne pas
faire n'importe quoi ni nous ni les
promoteurs ni tous ceux qui auraient des
velléités pour faire que les espaces
verts disparaissent sur plaisir il en
est pas question
il reste moins d'une minute justement à
quoi elle pourrait ressembler cette
ville
plusieurs dons qu'elle aura beaucoup
plus de trame verte beaucoup plus de
trames bleues puisque nous avons
également le reiki travers si on veut en
faire quelque chose sur lequel on duquel
on pourrait se promener il pourrait y
avoir aussi aux des parkings qui
pourrait être supplémentaires mais moins
visibles puisque réfléchir autrement
pourquoi pas en souterrain un centre
bourg historique beaucoup plus travaillé
au niveau de petites places de commerce
de proximité ce qui me semble
fondamental puisque à plaisir nous avons
un manager de ville qui gère les
commerces de proximité et on est très
attaché à ce et aussi des lieux de vie
c'est quelque chose qui nous semble
important et ce qui est important aussi
c'est le lien entre les quartiers
puisque comme toutes les villes et bien
de la zone nous sommes quartier risée et
je souhaite véritablement faire quelque
chose de plus cohérent
merci joséphine coleman ce berger
d'avoir été avec nous mais les
républicains de plaisir et toute
l'actualité de la ville est à retrouver
sur son site internet qui s'affiche
le salon de l'agriculture se poursuit à
paris c'est jusqu'à dimanche à la porte
de versailles un événement durant lequel
les yvelinois se distinguent elles les
yaourts y ont reçu hier la médaille
d'argent du concours agricole qu'avec
catégorie à yaourt nature brasser cette
start up basée à bouafles fabrique ses
productions grâce au lait de la ferme de
thiverval grignon le chef thierry marx
et les cuisines est notamment du palace
le crillon propose d'ailleurs ce yaourt
yvelinois autres récompenses la ferme
expérimentale de grignan toujours qui
décrochent est la médaille de bronze
pour sa crème dessert au chocolat
toute cette semaine justement notre
dossier de la rédaction est consacrée à
l'agriculture yvelinoise suite et fin ce
soir dans le futur qui s'opèrent est dès
aujourd'hui les exploitants font de plus
en plus appel aux nouvelles technologies
à saint martin de brit en cours par
exemple a mûri
babeau cultive le blé l'orge et la
betterave sucrière depuis quelques
années ils utilisent drones gps pour
l'aider dans son travail au quotidien
l'agriculture à l'ère du 2.0 c'est un
sujet de quentin le frère et michael et
demi d'euros on est parti
c'est devenu un outil de son quotidien
depuis trois ans plusieurs fois par
semaine à vos ribab aux jeunes
agriculteurs de 27 ans sort son drôle
pour contrôler les 160 hectares
d'exploitation de la ferme de la brosse
sans se déplacer sur le téléphone j'ai
la joie la caméra du drone est en fait
après j'ai un joystick pour montées
descentes et accélérer freiner et après
j'ai un bouton pour prendre des photos
un bouton pour prendre des vidéos
[Musique]
exploitation en parallèle de son drone
personnel à bord y fait également appel
à une société extérieure qu'il rémunère
10 euros de l'hectare pour étudier du
ciel ces parcelles via des droits
professionnels et de les termites sont
ensuite envoyées à l'exploitant plus et
rouge - il ya deux feuilles et moyens de
culture et plus et vert foncé plus il ya
de feuilles et plus de culture donc ça
veut dire que là où il ya plus de
feuilles plus de culture on apportera
moindre regret que là où il y en a moins
autre investissement consenti par cet
agriculteur en 2012 un gps à 12000 euros
pour ce prix les radars sont précis
entre 2 et 10 cm sur les modèles à
l'antenne c'est elle qui est directement
liée au satellite qui permet de savoir
on est dans le champ et puis après à
l'intérieur on a un écran qui permet de
visualiser ce que vos objectifs répartir
de façon homogène longrée sur les
parcelles ce système lui permet de
gagner près d'une heure et demie sur une
journée
on pas jamais deux fois au même endroit
et au moins comme ça la pénibilité on
est moins fatigué à suivre le traceur
toute la journée
on est plus concentré sur la machine et
à régler l'outil
arrières un gain de temps et un confort
de travail surtout aussi aujourd'hui cet
agriculteur 2.0 veut continuer à
investir dans de nouvelles technologies
et prévoit l'achat dans les deux ans
d'une machine pour désherber qui
fonctionnerait avec des caméras
autoguidés qu'au total de l'opération
20000 euros après cinq ans un nouveau
bail jusqu'en juin 2000 23 la direction
du théâtre montansier à versailles a été
reconduite par le conseil municipal de
la ville bonsoir geneviève dichamp la
codirectrice du théâtre montansier en
duo avec frédéric franck vous êtes à la
tête du théâtre depuis juin 2013
le fait d'être voilà reconduit à la tête
de ce théâtre pour cinq ans quel
sentiment cela vous inspire la d'abord
nous sommes heureux de continuer notre
action et puis ça permet vraiment de
continuer le projet qu'on a initié
depuis je m'intéresse à dire une
collaboration alternative entre le
théâtre privé et le théâtre public pour
le meilleur sur le plateau du montansier
choisir les plus beaux spectacles et
coproduire alternativement théâtre
public théâtre privé avec des grands
metteurs en scène et c'est ce nouveau
projet justement qu'il ya joué je vous
pensé dans la reconduction de votre
direction c'est le fait de mettre en
place ce nouveau projet oui c'est ce qui
a joué c'est pas un nouveau projet c'est
la prolongation de ce projet qu'on leur
mission et c'est vraiment l'excellence
choisir ce qui nous semble le plus beau
pour ce théâtre magnifique qui vient de
fêter ses 240 ans quel bilan vous vous
tirez justement sur la les premières
cinq années vous avez passées à la tête
du théâtre
alors d'abord le théâtre retrouver
vraiment une place dans l'espace
professionnel
on a aujourd'hui un public qui vient de
toute l'ile-de-france 50% de la ville
50% extérieurs dont des parisiens ça
c'est une vraie satisfaction
on a co produit des spectacles qui
tournent sur dans toute la france et
même quelquefois à l'étranger des
spectacles qui ont été qui ont reçu des
prix qui ont reçu vraiment la
reconnaissance du public et des
professionnels et donc c'est un théâtre
c'est ça c'est un rayonnement au-delà de
la ville c'est l'accueil de grands
artistes mais c'est aussi l'aide aux
artistes émergents
on a aidé des metteurs en scène qui
aujourd'hui ont passé 1
on va dire un étage c'est satisfaisant
aussi de pouvoir aider de coproduire des
metteurs en scène reconnu mais aussi
aider des jeunes parce qu'il faut comme
pour le public il faut aussi favoriser
l'émergence de nouveaux talents
juste pour représenter le théâtre pour
ceux qui ne le connaissent pas il y en a
sûrement le théâtre montansier vous
l'avez dit a fêté ses deux cent quarante
ans l'an passé un lieu inauguré par le
roi louis saez en 1777
est ce un théâtre à l'italienne un
théâtre à l'italienne c'est à dire un
théâtre rond qui permet une très forte
proximité entre le public et les
artistes très bonne acoustique et un
écrin dont l'accès des corps quand même
donne sur le bassin de neptune en
moyenne c'est combien de spectacles par
an le ses 120 lever de rideau et c'est
45000 spectateurs
45 spectateurs est-ce que vous pensez
que le théâtre vallée versailles et
peut-être même les franciliens vous
disiez des parisiens même qui viennent
au théâtre sont attachés à ce théâtre
ils sont très attachés clairement c'est
un théâtre qu'ils aiment dans lequel ils
se sentent bien nous on favorise aussi
beaucoup les contacts avec les
spectateurs ont fait beaucoup de visites
historiques ont fait découvrir les
dessous
l'arrière scène accéder corps voilà on
favorise beaucoup ce dialogue avec les
spectateurs
ce que le théâtre c'est pas simplement
un acte de consommation prendre un
billet c'est aussi rencontrer les
spectateurs c'est monté aux bars et on
organise des débats des on répond sur
les réseaux sociaux voilà l'importance
de de pouvoir favoriser les échanges
entre l'artistique et les spectateurs
l'ajustement sur la programmation est ce
qu'il ya un créneau qui est respectée
chaque année un fil rouge par saison
comment comment ça se passe cette
excellence voilà on essaye vraiment de
d'abord ne pas répéter de saison en
saison
des recettes mais vraiment de trouver
chaque année des artistes exceptionnels
des metteurs en scène qui ont des vrais
projets et qu'on va pouvoir présenter
pour les versaillais comme ont coproduit
à certains spectacles qui ne viennent
par exemple qu'à paris et versailles
mais pour les deux cent quarante ans
du théâtre qu'est ce que vous avez pu
proposer on a proposé un spectacle dans
les décors prêté par le château de
versailles des petits théâtres de la
reine donc ça c'était vraiment tout à
fait exceptionnel de pouvoir montrer des
décors quasiment de l'époque de
l'inauguration du théâtre qu'est ce que
cet anniversaire continue jusqu'à la fin
de la saison 2016 2018 plus vraiment
mais on y fait encore référence et là on
présente alors un spectacle un texte de
68 mais beaucoup plus anciens puisque
c'est l'adaptation de rabelais qu'avait
fait jean louis barrault en 68 19
comédiens sur scène pour une première
qui aura lieu mardi prochain
qu'est ce qu'il ne faut pas manquer la
d'ici à la fin de la saison le rabelais
mise en scène par hervé van der meulen
mais aussi l'impératrice groupe
d'électro pop qui explose le 16 mars
dans le cadre d'un festival électro chic
monté avec versailles grand parc mais
aussi la mort de tintin gillham
interlink auteur un peu oublié qui a
reçu le prix nobel de littérature
et puis la nostalgie des blattes avec
catherine hiégel grandes comédiennes de
la comédie française
et puis on prépare de beaux projets pour
la saison prochaine avec des grands
comédiens pleins de choses à ne pas
louper pour retrouvez toute la
programmation du théâtre montansier je
vous invite à vous rendre sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci geneviève dichamp sa mort était
avec nous je rappelle codirectrice du
théâtre montansier à versailles
on continue de parler culture le
week-end dernier la compagnie a des
tisseurs de son jeu proposé une journée
dédiée aux enfants à voisins le
bretonneux ateliers et représentations
ont rythmé cet événement nicolas landry
et mélanie poker se sont glissés parmi
les participants
samedi pour maxence et ses copains
c'était atelier musique
on a écrit une chanson pour un peu faire
réviser le spectacle de ce matin qui par
une pierre gobinet parleurs 15,8 non
testé les instruments qu'ils avaient
ramené j'ai chanté avec le violoncelle
et la guitare avec c'est mon beau linge
et ils ont pu essayer des instruments
simon c'est le compositeur de la
compagnie thyssen de songe à l'origine
de la journée marmailles et marmots
destinés à la jeunesse
c'est un sujet qui nous parle beaucoup
puisque au sein de la compagnie nous
sommes tous artistes pédagogues se dire
qu'on est tous professeurs des
enseignements artistiques donc que ce
soit de théâtre de musique une journée
conclue par une farce à celle d'angelo
d'ibeo lcos dire usante qui revient de
guerre des textes anti militariste des
xvième et xviième siècle présent ce
paysan du soldat parti guerroyer pour
revenir et of plein de butin
on a travaillé sur un grand nombre
d'adaptations et les traductions pour
vraiment avoir un texte déjà qu'ils
puissent être entendu qui puisse être
qu'on puisse dire est qu'on puisse jouer
et ce comme c'est un spectacle destiné
quand même tout public et un tout public
jeunes à partir de 6 7 ans faut aussi
que le texte soit suffisamment
compréhensibles pour tout le monde et
c'est un spectacle qui mêle aussi la
musique
donc il ya deux chansons qui encadrent
le spectacle un peu vraiment la manière
d'un spectacle de très tôt un spectacle
presque un spectacle de rue cet éveil
artistique était aussi la conclusion
d'une semaine de travail
la compagnie était en résidence à
l'espace de covile de
voisins-le-bretonneux
[Musique]
avant de se quitter on vous en a parlé
le froid frappe le département et
n'empêche qu'il faut retourner au jardin
pour préparer le retour de la belle
saison l'association jardins passions
partage à guyancourt
elle nous a ouvert ses portes regardez
ce reportage de camille lambert et
nicolas d'andré sas assure des vols
d'hivernage on les cours pour réchauffer
un peu la terre pour préparer la culture
comme ça pendant pendant trois semaines
ou un mois ça réchauffe un peu la terre
malgré le froid à les trahir sa came
plus chaud mais après ça va activer la
levée des semis dans quelques semaines
carottes et poireaux seront plantés dans
ces bacs de permaculture une technique
de jardinage bien particulière qui
permet d'économiser l'eau grâce à
différentes couches de terre c'est grâce
à l'humidité qui retiennent au fond de
la deûle à de la butte
on a mis des branches d
et nikos sarah dars le but d'été et en
plus ça décompose l'économie d'eau et de
travail aussi parce que comme ça on a
moins à désherber moins arrosées et ça
pose beaucoup mieux présidente d'une
association de jardinage à guyancourt
hank de fo est une véritable passionnée
elle fait régulièrement découvrir son
jardin et donne ses conseils aux
visiteurs
malgré le froid hivernal elle se prépare
déjà au retour des beaux jours
l'intérêt très émue et pas trop froid
c'est presque bon pour faire du sommet
en attendant la jardinière surveille ses
protégés qui ont passé l'hiver dans
leurs cabanes et celles à faire il faut
détailler un travail régulier partagé
depuis quatre ans avec son association
de nombreux ateliers sont organisés pour
apprendre à avoir la main verte
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal un
rappel vigilance de mise ce soir la
neige devrait faire son retour dans les
yvelines le département est placé
d'ailleurs encore une nouvelle fois en
vigilance orange par météo france
1 à 3 cm de neige attendues poids lourds
et bus sont d'ores et déjà interdits à
la circulation sur la n118 et ce à
partir de 22h et la préfecture des
yvelines qui appellent demain les
automobilistes à emprunter les
transports en commun enfin je rappelle
que le plan grand froid lui reste
activée il a permis depuis son
déclenchement d'ouvrir 3102 places
supplémentaires d'hébergement en ile de
france cette édition vous pouvez bien
sûr la revoir comme tous nos programmes
sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile la tv
soixante dix huit belles soirées à tous
sur tv 78
[Musique]